[Musique]
contrairement aux idées reçues le budget
alloué par l'état ces quartiers et 30%
inférieur au reste de la france
celui de la culture il est inférieur de
300% les transports ils sont six fois
plus compile compliqué qu'ailleurs
sans parler d'accès à la santé au
logement ou à l'emploi bref tous les
sens d'entrée dans la république sont
défaillants la banlieue et ses habitants
sont souvent discriminés et stigmatisé
ils sont maintenant méprisés pire ils
sont mis au ban de la république car
c'est toute la promesse d'égalité que
vous avez enterré parce que nous ne
voulons pas vos rescrit libéralisme
inégalités et adverse sur le fronton de
nos mairies ma question est simple allez
vous enfin faire république où allez
vous aggravez l'apartheid territorial ce
que nos ce que nos concitoyens attendent
ce ne sont pas une accumulation de plan
ce sont des actions des actions il y en
a déjà eu il y en a déjà eu sur l'école
il y en a déjà eu sur les emplois francs
il y en a eu en matière économique
il y en a eu en matière sociale et nous
allons continuer et ce qu'a indiqué le
président de la république indiquant que
dès le mois de juillet un certain nombre
d'opérations serait mis en place
j'aurai l'occasion de revenir aussi sur
la modification de l'anru sur
l'accélération des dossiers sur les
engagements sur la simplification et
bien oui
aujourd'hui ça ne fonctionne pas très
bien mais ça ne fonctionne pas très bien
la rue depuis plusieurs années et nous
savons tous pourquoi
eh bien nous allons y mettre de l'ordre
et nous allons faire avancer ce dossier
avec des engagements qui ont été pris
par le président de la république et qui
seront mis en application d'ici la fin
de l'année
c'est un camouflet c'est une déception
sévère est amère pour les élus locaux
pour les associations de proximité mais
aussi pour les habitants à qui on doit
redonner de l'espoir et l'envi de la
france pour tout cela monsieur le
ministre il faut avant tout rétablir
l'ordre et la sécurité de manière totale
et pérenne en luttant contre l'économie
souterraine
et les trafics qui gangrène le tissu
social en mettant fin aux barbaries des
voyous en mettant fin au communautarisme
en mettant fin au prosélytisme islamique
alors monsieur le ministre tant les
principes de la république
vont ils pouvoir être retrouvés dans ces
territoires oubliés de la république
l'engagement de ce gouvernement et
d'augmenter de 1300 places de
fonctionnaires de police d'ici à 2020
dans 60 quartiers prioritaires
ces images insoutenables que nous avons
vu à marseille il y a quelques jours
conduira très directement à plus de 60
nouveaux renforts qui seront déployés
d'ici le début de l'année prochaine
il précise également les liens devant
être fait pour lutter profondément
contre les trafics de stupéfiants
les liens devant être faits entre police
municipale et police nationale pour
lutter contre la radicalisation et
l'identification des éléments les plus
dangereux
et puis le président de la république
rappelle également que cette république
pour tous et partout
elle passe par une émancipation elle
passe par la lutte contre cette
discrimination insoutenable pour les
jeunes de ces quartiers par le fait qu'
aujourd'hui sous prétexte que en haut à
gauche de votre cv vous ayez une adresse
politique de la ville vous avez
aujourd'hui entre deux et trois fois
moins de chances d'avoir un entretien
d'embauché mais également que cette
émancipation elle passe par des places
de crèche
elle passe par le doublement des classes
dans l'éducation elle passe par près de
2 milliards d'euros investi dans la
formation professionnelle pour les
jeunes et les moins jeunes de ces
quartiers éloignés de l'emploi et donc
la question au final c'est pas est ce
qu'il ya un plan est ce qu'il n'ya pas
de plan est ce qu'il ya une vision une
volonté la réponse est clairement oui
est ce que nous irons jusqu'au bout la
réponse est clairement oui nous ne
lâcherons rien
[Musique]
ce